hey everyone
hello margaret felix
v kevin
awesome to be here with you thank you
thank you such a pleasure
pumped we were actually just having a
great
conversational point and i would love
for
v to continue on it
okay i don't know if you mean the part
about
the usefulness of dancing duality
correct that part
integration in the evolution of life in
incarnation
the utility of a duality
and juxtaposing that with abiding in i
am
and since the subject of this video
uh has been set as the
balance of feminine divine with
masculine divine it's very
much in line with the consideration of
duality
one of the expression of duality being
feminine as the backdrop to masculine
and vice versa
and what i was sharing in the studio
before we went live was
uh the introspection i went through last
night
trying to find an imbalance
within my being in order to expose it
and
and purify it
but the more i searched
every shadow of impurity i could
imagine or
start to believe i was finding was
dissipating as i
tried to formulate it
and but i still managed to reach a
a foundational
solidity which even though
it was not entirely i am
it still felt balanced as well it still
felt
in fact imbalanced but harmoniously
imbalanced
like a dance what is a dance
it's
a person or a person's
falling it's a constant
imbalance captured by another imbalance
by another imbalance this is what is
advanced
um perfect balance is not a dance
it's immobility a dance
is imbalanced but it's harmonious
imbalance
the only difference is whether you find
beauty and
joy and satisfaction and fulfillment and
expression of your truth
in that dance or not and then it becomes
a dance
if it has that quality or
it it is a falling on imbalance or
stumbling
if you don't find the harmony and the
beauty
and the coherence with your being in
that dance
and it's difficult enough to dance on
your own
but it's very enjoyable
um it's
it's amazing i even
find it more nourishing
and more restful than silent meditation
sometimes
and i have not given up on the hope
of that same level of quality of harmony
and beauty and intimacy
in a dance with other reflections of the
one infinite being
so this is where i landed last night and
where it ties in with
today's subject is that the
the most beautiful
uh multi-dancer dance i can imagine
has to be the bible
the the bipolar dance
between one masculine divine
interpretation
and one feminine divine interpretation
but to be honest in this incarnation
i have come very close to it i have even
experienced it on
very short
instances
and i have not given up on experiencing
it more fully
and i'm i'm not interested in giving it
up
before i have exhausted the
the
the delving and the basking into that
energy and vibration for
a little bit
at least to my satisfaction that's what
i would contribute
i have a feeling that kevin may have
some thoughts about what you just said
especially with his
really strong resonance with
balancing distortions with catalysts
like is taught in the lav one and what
v was just referencing
yeah so what came true was uh
something about the low one and uh
our creation is explained
there so at first there is uh
infinity
and this infinity then
become aware of itself and when it
becomes aware of itself
is a intelligent infinity
and for a long time i tried to
find the references of the universal
masculine
and the universal feminine in
the low one but i didn't find
anything like that because probably
ra and uh the channel laura
didn't use this term but uh
to me seems that uh the universal
masculine and the universal feminine
feminine
is actually the intelligent infinity
and this union
creates all creation their relationship
is the reason of why we are here
and so i agree with the dancer that
connecting with the other reflections
and the dance of duality
is a dance that can be a louder
with no distortion when we rest
more and more into the space it seems
yeah um i really like
v what you said about
[Music]
harmonious imbalances
[Music]
um
because it seems to me that it's um a
core part of the process of
expansion to um
to realize or to discover that some
imbalance that was perceived on some
level
at some point we can gain a broader
point of view
where this imbalance is actually
included
in a greater harmony
and so i feel that in this way the dance
actually
grows and expands
it's not like a static dance between two
denser it's like
the movement of the denser grows and
encompasses more and more of the
totality
and and it very much feels like it's
it's like
putting some salt in your food this
this imbalance or distortion
it actually reveals more of the
the flavors the more the beauty more of
the harmony
like it creates some contrast it creates
some some depth
to the experience
a great do you have thoughts on this
okay do you have thoughts on this
yes yes i do i actually um
on my beginner level i guess
i have experienced that
i guess on my on my quest to wholeness
i have experienced the catalyst that i
guess triggered me to
try to become whole and
part of it was i guess
including the masculine into the
feminine
in a way
and trying to balance them both
into becoming the whole person or the
whole
person that i thought that i was
becoming but
little did i know that it wasn't about
being a person
and exactly like he said that the dance
of
of those both energies and
and that you know the
feminist feminine and masculine
energies just dancing around and trying
to you know
trying to to make this wholeness workout
so so
i see those energies on both i guess on
that on the
on the universe level and on the micro
universe
that the inside of me which is really
one and saying we all know that
level how it all affects
how it all affects the world
and and our i guess our own
individual souls
and how it really when you really go
down to
to it on the very very intimate level
it really is one and the same
like when i really thought about it or
didn't think about it like really
skip the thought process
i didn't see the difference between that
it really is one
but you kind of have to go through the
process it's like
the signposts get to that point
eventually
i don't know if if you follow my train
train of thought
it's really still pretty where i am but
it's not the train of thoughts
describing what you see there is a
minimum level of thought
necessary for language and that's it
[Music]
if you are going to talk about it at all
then
yes it will help to involve a little bit
of thinking
to put it into language but i think we
all agree that
we could easily replace feminine and
masculine
with dark and light or any other
expression of duality
and
i assume most of us or all of us
on this panel all of us have had the
experience of
turning inside out and outside in
and finding out our true nature
and then because we are still here
we it means we chose to still
look at the universe from the
inside out point of view
because if we i only assume that
if one chooses to maintain
the outside in point of view
i'm not very sure if our incarnation
would
still appear to others or if there would
still be others
for it to appear to so the fact that
we're on this panel
is that we for some reason it might be
different from each one of us
we chose to maintain uh
and sustain or attach
to the point of view from inside out
rather than outside in or vice versa you
can look it up
any way you like or from the feminine
to the masculine or vice versa or from
the light to the dark or vice versa
and that was the conclusion of my
introspection last night is that
i saw that i'm still
interested in that dance i want
to refine it perfect it and
mesmerize myself and the universe
which is myself i want to mesmerize
myself
in a in an even more expansive
harmonious and intimate
dance and
one of the ways i like to visualize
the movements before i do them when i
dance
or when i dance live or when i dance on
music
it begins with visualization of what
movement
is most coherent
and expressive of the vibration of the
music i hear
and i tried to make my body
just be an extension
a reverberation of the vibration of the
music
and then suddenly i'm not there anymore
then i lose track because
i'm not a dancer
and there is no music anymore
it's there's only a dance
happening and
whenever that state
is entered it's dancing or sometimes
exchanging with somebody or with
people or or sometimes just
expanding into an observation
uh yes there is nothing exists anymore
then whatever is happening there is only
a happening
and that that is intimacy that's what i
call intimacy
it's when into me i see
and i am
that i am that being whatever i'm doing
whatever is happening in fact because
there's no more doer
so
and there's less and less possibility
of putting it into work
by the way there might be a copyright on
this into me i see for intimacy because
this is something that was picked by uh
vincent in a movie called
with mike myers called
the guru or something like that it was
hilarious and but by the way it was
deeper than it
than it came to be
but it's a
it's incredible how when you are not
there anymore
life happens and you suddenly discover
the true hidden it's not hidden it's in
plain sight the true meaning of
of words that the intended meaning of
words
appear to you in that intimacy
just like
the true
purpose of your skin is discovered
in the arms of your beloved
yeah and what came true
yeah as you said this is a really a
dance that
has to be allowed because
if i'm here in this moment attached
to my point of view i cannot allow
this uh dance to happen the
intelligent energy cannot flow
through me maybe you're at a party
and you're scanning the environment and
you're reading
you cannot dance you're stuck
but in the moment in which you let go in
the moment in which you don't care
the moment you reach your lives more of
this i am
suddenly you dance and then everybody
dance around you
and uh it is beautiful though
it is beautiful now and uh so
in that tai chi in tai chi chuan when
you play with the partner if you do the
tweet show
yeah exactly that's a good example of uh
when somebody is really into that
vibe then with time is going to
influence
all the environment because it's gonna
give a
permission to all
the people from frieza
and uh to just be
i love this one such a good example
yeah the first one is the catalyst
unlocking the will of the other ones to
play yeah the first one
is not there
he's still there but himself slowly
the dance is what happens when the dance
says
right
yeah in the dance
i noticed that well i'm
i'm not completely new to this concept
either in
in shamanism there is such thing as
becoming the hollow bond
so the spirit flows through you you are
just the
conduit for it and
for me there is this experience of
you don't even exist as the bomb really
there is like you you kind of disappear
from city
when you're when you just relax but it's
when you disappear that you are the most
authentically present it is exactly
if you got it it is so awesome
yeah but to a large extent duality is
just
the tension between who between
what you are and who you think you are
and
so the dance is really it's really the
reconciliation
because it's that we could replace dance
by making love or by
com exchanging uh any
anything right it's really about
reconciliation
of what you are with who you think you
are and when you allow those two to make
love to
to to get in union uh
you are finally whole you are finally
whole
as you were always but without the
this withholding
of that belief of not being
of being separate and you know even in
the
in the christian bible jesus
was proponing was
asking people to to enter into the
nuchal chamber
the new you know chamber
and he was he mentioned to to his
disciples when they were criticizing
whether
mary magdalene should be part of the
group or not
and he said don't worry i will make her
mail so that she can
enter the kingdom like
and of course in the culture of the time
he
or at least was not reported i doubt he
didn't say
also the reverse that as a male you have
to make yourself female to enter the
kingdom
and as a female you have to make
yourself male but
he's not talking about bisexual
bisexuality he's just
talking of those two fundamental
principles of masculinity femininity
dark and light you are and who you think
you are
all of that allowing it to accept each
other
and to merge and be in union and in
unity
and finally be one himself
and then when you are
nobody when you're really
disappearing when your edges between you
and everything else
this all everything else dissolves it's
like
it's just like magic then everything
else is you
and everyone everybody else is you
it's still really it's still yeah you
see
it reachable by just a little bit of
focus
but anytime you defocus your all that is
anytime you focus
you can choose any
piece you want to separate
and then you can zoom out or
defocus and be all zoom in
zoom in more be vincent
zoom in even more and be lost
in hunger or in greed or in joy or in
whatever
narrow expression of the narrowest
identity that
you want and you relax
and you are again all that is and you
focus on compact and you are again kevin
or maldo or felix or allen
yeah and you relax a bit you are now at
class or
whatever name you choose for a slightly
higher being
and then you relax again and you are
another you can give
yourself another name as a wider
consciousness
and you relax even more and you are
as far as you can tell all that is
but more and more in my experience
i feel that even our most
extreme enlightenment experience or
awakening experience or satori
is still it still has a circumference it
still has a certain radius
of limitation of consciousness so
i don't think there is ever going to be
an end to our capacity to be
more of all that is and all that is not
and whatever we can't even conceive of
and
and um
yeah but
there is still room
there's still room for roomy
yeah i noticed that like every time i
think oh this
can't possibly get any better and then
the next day whoa
something new right but there's a
another mountain to find
it's really awesome
yeah i feel this is a great gift
of the creation of limitation
is that it uh it allows for infinite
expansion
yes and we co-created i'm sorry
i'm sorry go ahead yeah so in this way
it finds also this complementary aspect
of the other dancer so from the limited
perspective you find
the infinite and vice versa
the infinite then also includes the
finite
yeah this is such a wonderful
conversation
i just read something uh from the low
one info
and i will just read that yeah
so the part that touched me was uh
the mind body spirit uh in its eternal
dance of the present
maybe streaming totality this just
brought
the realization that actually everything
is dancing right now
all of this vibration from which light
is made of
it's dancing right now at a certain
frequency
and that the more we raise our frequency
the more
we dive deep into the oneness that we
all are
the more these all realities ends up on
a faster rate on a faster day than a
faster rate
emitting a more of a beautiful sound of
a beautiful song
so the dance is happening spontaneously
and the song along with it
yeah the truth is
the the music is still a mystery to me
but the the understanding of the dance
of the universe is
it's very concrete very it's my
experience
it is um i discovered it
a few years ago well quite a few years
ago when i was asked you know
socially you always ask what do you do
and it's so uninteresting
but i the person asking me the question
that they
came from a place of of honesty and
authenticity so i wanted to give him a
honest and true answer
even though i found it a boring question
in nature
but i i answered i'm a dancer
and uh and it it was the
more honest and true answer i felt i
could give even though i know what he
was expecting is
uh i'm an engineer or i'm an
entrepreneur i'm an investor
i am in the energy or whatever
and the guy actually uh because he saw
so that i was being honest
he actually thought that i may have i
may have i may be
a retired dancer that got a bit of
weight or something
like that
but it was an attempt at answering
honestly
and i it made it clear to me that
at least to this
uh point from this point of view
yes life is a dance
and when i dive into that and i try to
understand
okay then i can totally understand that
i am the dancer
i am the dance i am the scenery i am
everything the the the choreographer
the spectator the scene
the dancer the only thing i'm not sure
is if i am the music and so i think in
that analogy which is just an analogy
anyway
but i think it's deep and for some
reason
i can very easily see that i am all of
the components of the dance but i am not
the music
the music is still coming from a more
and even more mysterious place than
all that is
is the is the vibration that creates the
sound you know
so something happened
well you can create it by doing but for
most of
human beings the experience of sound is
through the vibration of
air that
reverberates in your eardrums and you
have some hair and eardrums that
translate that into an intelligible
vibration however you don't need to go
through air you can
go through any other matter like there
are now
many headphones which
are just touching your skill and the
vibration goes directly through your
scale without doing
without using the eardrums also the
human civilization is not located in
space as located on this habitable rock
this is also mysterious because
this is i saw it i i know
it because for a few years
i thought basically that
we are just consciousness
going through the cord of a
hop the heart being the cords of the
heart being tied
to earth at one end and tied to
whichever whatever is the foundation of
heaven at the other end
right and that then you can decide to
shift your yourself your consciousness
your finger
on that chord to get different
vibrations
and that's what i thought until
i realized that the encore point
at the core of earth and the anchor
point
at the foundation of heaven is one and
it's a single point
and that that the chord is is tensed
between the same point
and in a vortex like constant
uh it becomes uh very difficult to put
inwards but
i think we all have some experience
to connect that to
can we play with the idea of
why the music would be excluded
from the dance not excluded it's just
mysterious while i could clearly see
i am every thing of the dance
i could not experientially
find within myself the music
while it is there
or is it or is it
like this guy dancing in the field that
we watched just before
was there music
was there or is it absolute silence
maybe not yet be maybe you'll get a
catalyst that will make you realize
that you are music because you are
everything there is
that's also the the
conclusion that is that even the
perception of a dance
is just the visualization
of music maybe the closer you get to the
black
maybe the closer you get to the black
hole the
more you disappear and the music
disappears
what do you mean closer you know
the more you the more you what is what
do we mean by closer the more that you
swim in the most downstream contracted
energy of the person conditioning
the more you can clearly in a sense
see the massive slaps in the face of
catalysts
that come as sledgehammer swings and the
more that you
just abide in the very source
of infinite possibility that gives rise
to all phenomena
the more it's just just complete silence
possibly is that what margot just said
that you you introduced no no i just
wanted him to clarify what he means
but i guess i get what he meant
i wanted him to clarify i don't
i know what he's talking about if you
are going to make a juxtaposition
between a
here and a there that would be a way
that
intelligibly and actually uh
just speaking with you guys um
i can see that a very plausible
explanation for my inability to
identify with the music while i could
identify with
the dancer the dance the koi grapher the
scenery
everything is that all these
are separate concepts
of the one and single thing that exists
which is the music
or or the silence whichever way you want
to call it because
also from kevin yep so
this is something that they saw also in
our old porno pono
and by the way the question that
actually i was asking something
regarding music
and uh so what it seems is that uh the
more
we balance each of our energy center
the more we actually become the perfect
instrument
for the creator that we are so that we
may actually
create our own music and so we can see
this even in musical artists
every every single has its own
particular taste
every single has its own uniqueness
spark of the creator that uh ishii is
so the more that the singer is in tune
the more
that the music that will come true will
come from an inspired place that will be
able to catch a lot of people
and it seems to me that music or also
singing is a good analogy because
um a beautiful singer is not
um
doesn't make like a pure sound like uh
maybe uh
you could generate on a computer that
you could say like this is really a pure
sound like a pure
um like just the the most
precise oscillation
yeah so in in a in a single or
in a beautiful instrument also you have
many different vibrations that
go together and when it's beautiful
there is this harmony that
that ties all this frequency together
and there is a very strong taste a c
minor
from a violin or from a trumpet or from
any other instrument is extremely
different
from each other even though technically
it's supposed to be the same frequency
but we can taste the difference we can
smell
the difference we can feel it we can
raise on it differently with the same
frequency
depending on which instrument sends it
and this is this is really
the the most attractive and beautiful
experience in life is to
taste that but it's also what
is a little bit indigestible sometimes
when we
we put too much salt in our dish
and sometimes we even put msg
so you know it's funny because that also
reminded me of
what you said felix about the salt it
reminded me of
one other citation from
jesus in the christian bible that
he refers to those
to his disciples and so those who do the
union the with the father
in the neutral chamber so within
themselves
he refers to them as the souls of the
embarrassment
and he warns that you have to
to keep your saltiness so your taste
because what is even mentioned what is
salt
without saltiness is just dust to be
trampled on
so your your unity is truth
that is the and that is the the taste
that is your taste is your your unique
taste of the same vibration of truth
so and that's what
we can exchange that's it's probably the
only thing we can exchange
it's our imbalance our harmonious
imbalances and
and we can all work like like a chorus
you know like a
group of people singing together if they
are inexperienced
uh it would be a bit dishonest but if
if they are very professional and even
when they are very
strong they need a little bit of
adaptation to
to attune you know to to adjust
ever so slightly their
their tune to to the rest of the group
and to the partition
so i think in this nls farm
i would just coming to me that
it would be a very good analogy to
compare us to to the choir
in in the church in a way
so if we are going to sing the beautiful
inspiring
chorus song that will
inspire others to join in
or dance or you know in fact it's a
well it's a it's more than a choir it's
a it's a
multi-faceted and multi-media
show it's uh you know
i would not be surprised if we realized
that
even before the ultimate there is a
density
where uh trillions of beings of
seven eight nine density are actually
gathered
in a huge amphitheater amphitheater
and are waiting for the show to begin
now the show where where
7.8 billion humans plus trillions
of other life forms on this planet are
going to
finally do this beautiful musical
called life on gaia
and so each one of us has his own
music song dance to contribute to that
incredible multi-dimensional show
so it would be a seven or eight let's
say
okay five six dimension and
a five six density show of
like a very multi-dimensional
musical show on broadway but at the
cosmic
scale with trillions and trillions
of other beings saying okay what are
they going to do okay how is it going to
be
oh my god look at this look at this
acrobat
oh listen to that song oh wow
this guy's so daring oh look these guys
so or that
ladies look at how those two
are dancing you know like it's it's an
in unfathomable
richness of expression in
multi-dimensions
which could be a very um uh
satisfying uh event
even at the cosmic level even at
the sixth seventh or whatever density
we cannot really understand
why not see it sounds awesome
but here is my problem with it
i mean i lost all preference to like
good or bad every like no judging is
everything is like really awesome right
yeah in the show
what if this show is like really out of
tune
and nobody's gonna know well what is
what is that out of tune is part of the
show
what if the show also includes comedy
it also includes drama it also also
includes
tragedy it also includes love
story it also includes even boredom
everything is there whatever you like
is there it's
not graspable by the
characters in the show but as the actors
we understand it or as or maybe as the
actor
true
it's awful that's right it's all for me
for you
or me right
to draw attention to the
no disharmony awesome right
there is none of this harmony
yeah and it's funny the fact that uh
this is ra saying from uh fixed density
there is no disarmament but uh
for many of us in uh in third density
it seems that there is a disharmony and
uh
because uh in uh this density
for us it's relevant to have experience
of the disarmament and to have
experience
of this particular song that is
generated
in each moment from our collective
agreement but uh
we can start to experience more freedom
as we realize
that actually this harmony is just a
point of view
so it seems that uh this show is just a
bunch of
point of views dancing and there are so
many points of views
so you can uh sit you can relax
and we can watch this show from the
sixth density
from our highest self experience from
this iem state
where all point of views are
more and more one so there is a
less and less of an attachment there may
be
a a preference in this density of course
we're gonna have uh uh and this is just
a word
but uh we're gonna have a taste for
something
yeah i would prefer to have a better
nice experience
than a bad experience but
even if i'm gonna have experience of a
bad experience
i'm gonna feel a little bit bad but then
i can realize
okay there is no disarmament body is
fine all is well
yeah and from that also the environment
can shift
it's like a chinese shadow show you know
huh ruff ruff ruff oh no don't bite me
don't bite
i also love that picture that was shared
i think it was by ulam of that
child having his head crushed by the
boot of an adult
yeah and then you moved out and you see
the child is himself holding the boot on
his face and laughing
and i found it extremely
i find this very apt
very
very happy very
it's this is a great play this is so
true
this is what happens actually this is
probably
one of the most
strong mimetic representations
of simplified spirituality and
the more that we boil down spirituality
into memes like this
the faster we can catalyze awakening in
the third density
this is a core component of what we can
focus on
and accelerate the awakening
this way because this type of stuff is
highly adored
by the matrix yeah especially by the
younger ones
and you don't you cannot even
know how many people will be affected
positively uh by some of these
memes they are very powerful yeah here's
another one since we're already at it
just to give you guys another good
example
yeah i know exactly where it came from
yeah yeah
yep so there's this one and then there's
another recent one that
emerged that is also really strong
i haven't posted it on on my account yet
but one of my
one of my friends did that's really
strong there's this one which is really
good
you just posted this one
[Laughter]
seeking enlightenment inquire with it
where's the door
the door here
so there's that one i i adore it
shout out shiva stan we love you he was
just on the show
and then here's the other one girlfriend
promise me
to be normal around my parents this time
me okay i promise
her dad so what do you do for fun
me what do you mean by you
[Laughter]
yeah that's it
[Laughter]
so guys let me tell you a little story
about how i lost it first time
no not that one so
i got my awakening very spontaneously
based on my profound suffering
i just surrendered big time like with
every cell of my body
surrender to god i'm like just take me
out of this earth right
and then the next morning i woke up just
like
exactly like eckhart tolle right with
the diamonds
playing the music and it was just so
amazing and i didn't care and it lasted
for about two weeks and
everything was crystal clear and it was
amazing and the music and i was the
dancer and everything and
then i'm like oh this is nice i wonder
how long this is going to last
this is how you try to put the in the
time on the internet you're even lucky
that it lasted two weeks
it was amazing and i've been telling
everybody once
this is where i am and everybody's like
it is true that sometimes there are
fireworks like this
like incredible yeah but if i knew you
you would have told me like just don't
quit just relax
just take it right i didn't know any
better
i know and if it had helped
if it could have helped you would have
met me earlier or met
whoever was going to give you that
message
so it's the way it is
these fireworks are both very helpful
for the one experiencing it because now
you know it's true
and now you will not give up
even though you will go through
frustration it takes a lot of time
to realize how to to remember to really
remember to realize how simple it is and
how
accessible it is because it's that it's
it's the
last natural state but it
in practice it takes time because
there's always this attachment to the
fireworks
and so for yourself it's quite helpful
because you remember you will never
forget that and you know it's real so
you will not give up
ever you will always
be demanding for the absolute
however when you tell that experience
and that's why uh if you look at it even
though it's the most
fundamental event in their life
most masters don't tell too much about
their
extraordinary experiences because they
realize
how
unhelpful it's going to be to many
people who
will equate the fireworks to the
enlightenment and they will seek that
and seeking the fireworks
is like seeking god is like seeking
yourself
until you realize you're it it's uh
it's not gonna happen and when
and those people looking for fireworks
are automatically
diviated towards substances you know
chemical
substances or any other assistance for
altered states of consciousness which
can also do the trick in a way
but there will always be that doubt
whether it's true
which you don't have when the state
happened to you naturally
and the truth is it's much longer to to
reach the relaxation required for
the state to
for you to be in the state that continue
and everybody
describes the state of not being
if you are not using any help chemical
or otherwise or
or a master a living master it takes a
long time and you can give up
because you you you have always a
lingering doubt
okay and then if you visualize it as
something like that happening in your
in your bedroom
we'll delay it because you will keep
focusing and trying to
get that i'll also respectfully disagree
with the point slightly just by taking
the angle
of that if one
basically takes the
understanding of their attention
and they take their attention and then
they
put these fireworks
on every single moment
every billionth of a second our
fireworks
just right here
and if they do that process and they
sort of get used to every
moment being it just this eternal
fireworking
they can sort of become more and more
awakened to
this being free ineffable absolute
perfection
so there are different strategies to
said process of tapping into the quote
now already being free ineffable
perfection
and so this could be used as a strategy
no strategy can be used truth is a
pathless land yet there are
also the the strategy is the obstacle
that's the the the the whole difficulty
of this exercise is that strategy
is a contraction already
it's when it's when you give up is when
you finally give up
that you are ever going to find a
strategy
and a way to get there that you can
finally
relax sufficiently that's even the whole
story of the buddha
buddha it's when all his ascetism
yield no result and he was
absolutely exhausted that's when he gave
up under the body tree
gave up totally his search his life
everything the relaxation was put out
and it happened
same thing with the osho same thing
with all of us anyone who ever had a
satori
it was not because he it was not the the
success of his strategy
i don't believe that anyone achieved
that with the
successful strategy however i could be
wrong because i don't know everybody
yet many of those great masters talk
about the preparatory periods
of their practices that then yielded
them the ability to have the insight
as is taught across the traditions that
through the process of concentration you
still the mind more and more
which then enables you to gain the
insight into
the perfection yes and no
uh can
[Music]
yes partially in the sense that what is
the meaning of giving up
if you have not tried so in that sense
yes
the usefulness of all the efforts and
strategies
they are only useful in the sense that
you are not giving anything up
if you have not truly truly tried
but otherwise it's not
really it's not the yield of the effort
it's
it's just that there is no meaning in
relaxation and giving up if you have not
tried but
i please finish yeah actually that that
was kind of the point i wanted to make
that
it seems that ultimately speaking the
usefulness of the strategy is to
uh quickens the process of exhaustion
it's like is to to focus one's
uh intention and energy in a very
one-pointed way
to the point where it's realized that it
cannot be achieved
and then something that can break open
and the problem is if you are aware that
you are
consciously adopting the strategy of
exhausting yourself
that's another strategy it won't work
yeah
yeah yeah because in fact you have no
you're not giving up
in fact yeah exactly on your effort
to exhaust yourself to finally relax no
you can relax now
if you're going to have a strategy just
relax
i don't know i don't get it there was
really never any strategy for me
it was just i was just suffering so
so much and i just didn't want to i
didn't want to suffer anymore
i know it's just complete surrender and
every time i was just
going going with it and going with it
and i really believed that my higher
self just put me exactly through the
suffering i needed to go through
that was the way for me i believe that
some people maybe get to enlightenment
through the strategy
and through their gurus and that's
beautiful
good for them for me it was that hard
you need to forget it's your strategy if
you adopt that
but it reminds me of one of the
jokes that i found most funny
a long time in my childhood and in my
youth
which is objectively not funny at all
but i always laughed
out loud whenever i heard this some
british people
expressing their frustration of some
bad quality music or or boring situation
or
a painful situation and they would say
uh i give up take me to the back and
shoot me
you know like like the the military
militia would do of a of a stubborn
opponent they would take him to the back
of the building and shoot him
and then you are the one asking please
take me to the back and shoot me
my ears are bleeding of hearing this
horrible music
or this suffering and to a certain
extent when i was hearing you telling
your story
i felt that's what you asked the
universe please take me to the back and
shoot me
i did i did i did now i'm laughing at
myself i'm like
that's self-created first time in my
life
that i laughed to this joke and i'm not
the only one laughing
that's it that was it exactly but you
know when you're in it
it is just so real and you can't get out
because you're in the middle of it and
you're creating this hell for yourself
and
you're just such a victim you guys know
you've been probably in it or maybe not
maybe others
you want to experience paradise you're
obliged to invent hell as well
because that's the only way you will
experience paradise it's in contrast
to health because reality
that's also something i always liked is
people
telling their lovers i'll be whatever
you want
it doesn't make me laugh it makes me i
think this is a
beautiful expression of love even though
most people who say that don't mean it
and and most people who mean it
should not say it because the other
facet of themselves may not be as mature
as them
when yeah
so regarding the masculine and the
feminine
and regarding uh this dialogue what came
true
uh and maybe it's not really relevant
for everybody but
for me was kind of nice to explore even
in the way in which we go through
self-realization
there is that uh quote-unquote
penetration
and that the desire to go through
and that there is that expansion there
is that
surrender and uh
that seems to be a dance also a taste in
which we go through
the realization of the true nature that
is uh
beyond the penetration is beyond the day
of surrendering that
just is a source realization
and uh it's a nice uh dynamic that
can take place and even that the dynamic
cannot be seen as an expression
of source in each
moment i'm realizing that uh
if the faults come in mind that says i
should meditate for 20 minutes
that's a realization of what source want
to experience
in this moment and if
the realization that comes in this
moment is i should go
and learn a particular method
strategy technique is there because
it's relevant for that character and
even not that
fault is realized because that is what
source want to experience
you know that moment and as we progress
as we trust
that that is the source for which
everything is coming from
what comes true
is that uh yeah it just
source uh wanting to experience things
and uh it's funny we cannot give an
explanation
yeah that's beautiful but why when you
refer to source
you don't say i
another word for for that for sure aye
it's it's a it's an okay word
that i will not mine yet at the same
time a good
a good reason to not use i is because of
the no-self
and so no self enables
the more close nature
when you use i that's when you use
self and that is its own
aspect to the experience so if god plays
with
itself we ask what is
that which
comprehends god playing with itself
and so then that's where the no-self
component also plays
um please go ahead yes
again yes no um i made this suggestion
to kevin
for a very good reason because kevin can
say
i when talking of source
i will not make that recommendation to
host
people and in fact in a previous
discussion we had the atlas
on your channel i mentioned that the
word i should be avoided
most of the time by most people because
until you know who you are you should
not use the word i
but when you know who you are it's
probably one of the best available words
at our disposal if we are ever going to
talk
fair yep
so i will take the opportunity for the
viewers
who feel that they that they have
really got a true understanding
understanding of their true nature
i would recommend dare dare say
i when you
speak of the ineffable
source i am that i am
but for those of you those listening
who have not come to a full
understanding of who they are who have
not had
yet the exhaustion the
absolute surrender take me to the back
and shoot me
a moment and subsequent revelation
of their true nature stay away
from this word i and even from the word
you as much as you can
so what do they use what do we use i
guess
shut the [ __ ] up
you don't know who you are shut the [ __ ]
up
or or speak until you are exhausted your
your everybody around you their ears are
bleeding and they ask
take me to the back and shoot me
so at least you can enlighten others by
exhausting them
guys by the way i was not talking to you
i was talking generally
i get it i was talking generally
now you go here don't worry
by the way i'm sure some some uh
identified feminine divines
in the audience must have been triggered
by what i just said because
this was an embodiment of masculinity
apparently telling an embodiment of
femininity
there to shut the [ __ ] up which was not
at all what happened there
but for those who suffered that
that i didn't that lack belief
of lacking power as a female or as a
feminine expression
uh to to v to see anything
assembling masculine tell anything
sembling feminine to to shut up would be
extremely trickery
and part of the reason why it was said
some people in the audience needed
this violent trigger right now
there's an audience question we can
explore oh yeah
great all right cool so
laurel is wondering if anyone on the
panel has had breakthrough experiences
with 5
meow dmt that's precise
speculate on the s and speculate on the
similarities with meditation
yes thanks
like yoga okay
maybe i can share something yeah
um
yeah that's how i would spell it yan is
the path of self-realization
yes the masterless path right
okay go ahead felix yeah so i
i had a few experiences with the 5mi or
dmt um
which uh is a very important substance
and um should be an approach with scare
and yeah just not
[Music]
not a recommendation or an endorsement
but
can be an interesting experience
um
so yeah it it has been called the god
molecule
and um it seems to me that
it might be doing
the the molecule that carries the
closest
vibration to that of god
at least that is available at least that
i
i know of
and and actually very recently
i had a deep meditative experience
where i felt like very much being in the
[Music]
the same very very same space that
this molecule carries
and
how it happened to me was
uh bringing in contact uh
what what i would describe as the
beloved
which is like the
the purest essence of in loveness
of adoration of
this um
this very white potent
nectar of love
that feels so intimate and intense and
like the essence of the heart
and bringing that in contrast to
the absolute
which is beyond even being
so you've got like this most intimate
experience of beingness
contrasted by the fact that even being
is not
me and so for me it's like this
this this essence of the heart exploded
in a way like the the identification
there that was so intimate and intense
burst open and and what opened up was
very much the
[Music]
the same space that i i had experienced
uh
quite a long time ago with this uh this
molecule
so yeah that's
basically what i had to share about that
and um
yeah i never i never had that general or
this
very specific one i didn't
i never had the molecule but
i don't know about the experience i had
i had it multiple
times daily yeah yeah
okay
i never tried i'm scared actually of
trying that
you know oh okay that's interesting then
you should definitely try it
i'm not scared of that molecule but i'm
not interested
and i've not tried that one because
what i understand is that dmt is
produced by the body
so i don't feel the need to go
buy it from an intermediary if i can get
it directly
not that i'm stingy but
i like to drink directly from the sauce
whenever possible
um i did try
occasionally when i was younger a few
substances some of them
i found interesting fun helpful and some
uninteresting or unhelpful
but generally i would say that
to attain any state by with external
help
be chemical or
with the active guidance
it's great in the sense that it will
enable you to have less
doubt about the existence of these
states
so that's the positive side of it the
negative side is
you have always this temptation of
taking the shortcut
of reaching there as quick as possible
with help
and you don't learn the the knack
of getting by yourself
anytime you want so why
create a dependency a despondency or
dependency
on on a any dealer of of
or any gatekeeper of
uh to access something that you are
uh i think it's a great business model
i'll sell you a ticket to to
to be yourself i have unlimited supply
i can send to you at any price you want
to pay
go to my website just pay and get there
yourself be yourself
with the help of only 9.99 right now
[Music]
if you buy five if you buy five
i sell the tickets to be yourself by
bunch of five
so you can be five times yourself for
the price of four
now but by the way i'm ridiculing it but
of course
we were all suckers for it until we
finally find the way in
right when you realize that
when you realize that
this beautiful smile
we are all pale in comparison right
but that's in comparison exactly and the
most beautiful smile
is yours person
the most beautiful one is but you can't
see it
yes near death experience
yeah i read quite a few books about
neil death experience and they are very
very
very insightful very interesting
and very consistent by the way
from different editors different authors
different languages
unrelated accounts of mdes
and very consistent right
guys i would love to read to you the
morning
prayer of all pono pono
it's one of our
i am the i i come forward from the void
into light i am the breath
that nurtures life i am the emptiness
that allowness beyond all consciousness
the eye the eye they all the continuum
of mind with matters
i am then calming and outgoing oppressed
the invisible untouchable grease the
undefinable atom of creation
i am the i powerful powerful power
and basically this is a cleaning tool
they say and that you you can repeat
these multiple times per day to clean
all
distortions and we could even comment on
the traits that i come from the void
of neutral light that dance of mind
with matter then coming in the drawing
of
platform yeah i am the eye
i would even recommend to the audience
to pray in the shower
because water has a very
uh very strong catalytic
uh and soothing power
of uh absorbing uh
any uh of your vibration especially
those which are not most
in harmony with your own belief
so a prayer i am that i am
even if at first you don't even believe
it
it's very helpful and uh
this entity happened to to pray that way
without really knowing exactly what he
was doing
for a few months
whenever taking the shower and it was
very helpful very soothing it
transformed it contributed
greatly to transform his experience of
life
and then it paved the way it's not
the causation but it's a helpful
paving of the way for
higher and higher realizations after
that
and it doesn't matter that much if you
don't even believe it
at first if you say it feeling a bit as
a fraud
to declare out loud that you are the i
am
uh if as long as you do it in private uh
but what you should avoid
as much as possible is um
is uh doing anything that is not
in absolute authenticity in the presence
of others
but if it's in your own presence in fact
aloneness in solitude
in the solitude of your shower or if the
so in any
solitude moment it's extremely helpful
to express out anything
even and especially what feels
fraudulent
in you or what feels untrue or what
feels
sad or painful say it out loud in your
in your aloneness in the
in the melancholy
of your solitude be the
soothing voice and the honest voice
that says out loud what you know you are
not yet or you feel you know you are not
yet but
listen to your own voice telling the
truth while you
tell it it's [ __ ] and over time
the rules will swap where you will
actually
realize slow it slowly
that there is some truth in it and then
the ground will be paved for
grace but you cannot control you
never it's impossible to know when grace
will fall upon you and the revelation
of your true nature will explode within
you in its full
undisputable truth
it may manifest even in visual effects
but that's not
what matters and don't
despair also because you will quickly
have a crash landing after that when you
say oh i am god
and
because the eye saying that is not the
right eye
is you know it's one of your two eyes
the only eye that is the true eye is
your third eye
the one you don't know yet until you
know it and until you know only that
eye as being a true eye
so but
for those who have not yet had their
satori
only be allow yourself
total fraud expression
fake it till you make it in solitude
don't
ever fake it till you make it in public
because
it will haunt you
uh especially in this day and age where
everything is recorded
uh you might not appreciate
uh being confronted with your
imbalances your past imbalances it's not
helpful
but uh to yourself there is no limit
there is it's even an absolute
requirement of total
brutal absolute honesty brutal honesty
with yourself and then if you are even
lucky to have somebody who
you trust enough to be brutally honest
with like we
have this luck this amazing blessing all
of us in the
nls group we have a group of people we
can be totally open and frank and honest
about our [ __ ] or our
truth and it's it's amazing but it's
very rare you have to be
very careful before you
expose your [ __ ] to anyone else than
yourself
this question leads really well into
what v
just said beautifully
okay i only know the word autism
i can only guess the others
but okay ptsd is familiar so anyone has
a
personal experience with that just also
in general the
question is trying to address how
some of the neurobiological
restrictions for spirituality
if how people feel about that not proper
emotion regulation
okay i have a a specific
opinion on autism even though no member
of my family
has that condition but i've um i've
delved into it
uh quite extensively
um
there are two elements to it number one
it's usually
a gift by the entity
incarnating into them
for the acceleration
of realization of the surrounding
entities
it's also a gift for the person itself
sometimes people who have tend to over
rely on their own ability to provide for
themselves
they would incarnate in an entity that
needs
assistance where they cannot avoid it
but specifically for autism there is an
element of memory which is very
important and as you know
ego is memory it's a
it's a it's a reprocessing of memory
it's a
it's a flowed it's a flow
coloring and reprocessing of your memory
and what is autism autism is the is a
kind of deficiency
of the natural ability of your
mind and brain to erase
unuseful memories because
many people think that memory is a skill
no the ability to forget is a skill
the the natural
process of the brain is to store
everything in memory to commit
everything in memory and by the way if
you dig in your
unconscious and subconscious deep enough
you find all
the elements of your memory that you
thought were lost or
erased they are not really erased so
ego is a memory construct
autism is extreme memory with
very little erasing
while uh what we call emotionally mature
people are actually people who are very
good at erasing
or apparently erasing any element of
memory that is not consistent with their
narrative
with their their story and with their
identity so there is definitely a strong
strong lesson about identity around
autism
and each condition and each relationship
between
each of the 7.8 billion people
is a tailor-made experience for the
spiritual benefit of both entities so
so then you can call it anything you
like that because
any incoming any incarnated being on
this planet
is in that case right it's to a certain
extent
gaia is a mental institution
where we are all
crazy people believing we are napoleon
bonaparte or
felix or kevin and we are being slowly
and gently treated so imagine if the
whole universe is trillions and
trillions of entities and some of us are
deluded into thinking we are some some
some guy some some historic
character or some cartoon character
instead of
of what we are then okay we can
be sent here we are given the illusion
of
separate identity the illusion of time
so that we can work it out
and regain our sanity that's one way to
look at it the other way to look at it
is that it's a giant nursery
where we come here to mature into
fullness
of consciousness and another way to look
at it is a
giant show scene
it's a it's a theater venue for the
biggest greatest show of all time
literally but if
anyone of you have specific experience
about those
things which
all right so
that might be something interesting to
also consider is
the recognition because this happens to
me a lot too is like why not just stay
in emptiness
i mean there were a lot of great things
they're said but that's also something
interesting
to consider is just
staying in emptiness thank you for the
question
i don't have a perspective we've done it
for
ever so we are only not doing it for a
few million years
[Music]
why not and i would say because why not
why not incarnate why not experience
time why not have fun
or why not have misery which is another
misery being the preparation for fun
and fun being the preparation for misery
why not why not
thank you for the time on the eternal
stage
that we've had together this has been
great
love it super grateful our meeting of
souls costumes units in the
tornado vortexing endlessly
thank you thanks everyone thank you
thanks a lot
yeah margaret welcome to your first
official stream yard video this was a
lot of fun together
yes yeah we're looking forward to more
yeah
thank you and thanks everyone for tuning
in we love you very much
thanks for your great questions thanks
for
hopefully some of these epic convo
points
ended up landing let's we can go back
through some of them
dance equals harmonious imbalances
intimacy into me i see only the dance
duality the tension between who you are
and who you think you are
turn inward cessation of arguing with
god you can defocus
into all that is focus into separate
peace
in the balanced individual the energies
lie waiting for the hand of the creator
to pluck harmony from raw
and suffering the drill sergeant of
awakening
awesome all right like the video if it
brought you value
helps the algorithm subscribe if you
haven't yet to the channel share the
video with people that you feel like
this would resonate
who is leave us a comment below with
your thoughts
thanks again infinite gratitude
bye bye
[Music]
all right we'll stay in the studio and
we'll wrap in
five four three